I want to go back to the idea of the
dollar shortage first right which is I
think in the macroeconomic world and
people who manage money professionally
they really have a good grasp of that
would just spend kind of a minute
describing what that means in layman's
terms for people who aren't in that seat
and then we can get into kind of some of
the knock-on effects and why that's put
us in the position that we're in today
okay simplistically and again I would
say if you want to go deep go digging
all the macro voices guys simplistically
dollar shortage the dollar is the world
reserve currency that means a lot of
different things but it means that
countries around the world want to
transact in dollars dollar based
transactions financial contracts
liabilities financial instruments you
want to do that in dollars because you
feel good about the stability of what
that's going to be that creates what is
very broadly now been called the euro
dollar market which is basically all of
the dollar denominated liabilities and
financial instruments that exists
outside of the United States in thus
outside of the direct purview of the
Federal Reserve
and
when this dollar short situation was
which would have been again going on for
a year
close to a year i'ma get you know I
think the macro horses guys would
probably tell you it's been going on for
like five years if you want to go all
the way back to you know when you know I
guess when in like I guess foreign
buyers of Treasuries stops becoming net
like net purchasers of Treasuries which
I think was in fourteen I know that was
a big part of that kind of dollar how
that started
but you fast forward today and you have
a big deal leveraging event a market
crash like we had in March and the whole
world was already scrambling you know
barely getting enough dollars to satisfy
these various different you know
contracts and financial instruments and
then there's this big race for dollars
and you get it's just a vacuum and the
easiest way to think about how big that
vacuum was was that the fan in the
Treasury and the US government announced
north of seven trillion dollars of
monetary and fiscal stimulus from you
know over about a six week period of
time in kind of March April and the
Dixie the dollar index which is the the
US dollar weighted against the basket of
international currencies the Dixie was
unchanged over that period of time so
seven trillion of stimulus again you
only did you did like two trillion in
the financial crisis over a really big
multi-year period of time and we did
seven trillion in you know six weeks and
nothing happened to the dollar that's
how sure the world was dollars and so so
the setup that that puts in place is it
now puts the United States government in
a position to basically be shooting
against dollar weakness
with record levels of stimulus
unprecedented levels of stimulus I don't
know if you saw this statistic Goldman
put this out in their research about
three weeks ago the let me make sure I
get this
the disposable personal income in the
United States in 2020 Goldman predicts
to be 0.5 percent higher than in 2019
high basically flat let's call it flat
disposable income flat year how is that
possible that's possible because of the
magnitude of the fiscal stimulus the
United States is providing right now for
people in this in these unprecedented
times whether that's the right thing to
do or the wrong thing to do is not what
we're talking about right now and it's
almost like less interesting actually
just just identify what they're doing
and that's what they're doing and as
long as the dollar is hanging in around
here in my opinion it's giving the Fed
the Treasury the green light to keep
doing more and keep doing more and
that's basically what they're shooting
again